panic I checked my pulse and if I can
find it I know I've got a chance Paul
Newman today get the keys to my new
condo thinking about it brings back
memories of my first place I was moving
in and was both excited and nervous and
then I looked at my finances I had a few
months savings but that was it I
immediately thought what if I couldn't
afford this place how was I going to
keep paying for it how would I afford
the furniture that I needed and then
there's all the extra cost electricity
food insurance Internet how did money
just seem that evaporate from my account
the deeper I got into the numbers are
scarier it looked but I never thought
about going back I didn't regret making
the move something inside me told me it
was going to be okay I'd find the way I
had moments of panic though major panic
every time I had to write a check or
make a purchase I'd worry and I used
that worried and put it into my business
I stayed up late to do more work I
stopped playing computer games are
getting distracted by other things I
focused my effort i used my fear to push
me and I overcame I didn't use up all my
savings I didn't go bankrupt my business
picked up from all the hard work I was
putting in it worked out if you're
panicking right now the answer isn't to
retreat don't throw everything you've
done away you started this business for
a reason I need to see it through use
your fear as a motivator to work harder
and be more focused trust that
everything will be okay if you keep
doing the right things it might get
tough really tough well things will turn
out in your favor if you keep working
and are doing this for the right reasons
it's okay to panic totally natural just
don't let that panic hold you back from
doing something great believe